现在唯一需要理顺的关系是你要出去找到你自己的自信，
你要找到你的价值，
你要找到你事业奋斗的那个激情，
你要为自己的人生去盘算，
去为自己的养老去打算，
其他所有的事情的话都放在后面，
我来复述一下你的情况啊，
你们本来两口子感情，
一个人看来就特别特别的好，
就是逛街都能拉着手那种好。
你今年47岁，
有两个孩子，
完了之后这男的居然是在外面有外都已经十多年了，
你都没发现对吧？
等你发现的时候都好多年都过去了，
现在你俩是已经把那个证儿已经领了，
房子车子存款钱财都在你手上了，
是不是生娃贷娃以后母就没有管厂里面的生意，
他一个人折腾这几年，
他说亏了，
所以忙着车子，
他实际上是已经二次抵押了的，
抵押了他给我，
他现在是已经协议给我嘛，
他每个月照样去还那些东西，
孩子该负责的他也去负责，
他也在管，
该出那个学费啊，
该给他们的他也给，
但是她开始是没有钱，
然后外面那个呢，
确实也是为了一个保险什么之类的都贴上来的，
不止一个，
有两三个小女儿就才两三岁，
我就拿了证，
但是没有赶她出去，
房子车子说在我名下，
但是车子现在给他开，
然后也住在这里，
我就经常就这种情绪反扑，
你看这拿了证都十来天了吧，
就一直都是很难受，
因为我们做建材行业嘛，
已经是走下坡路，
他也说搞。
亏了，
我把厂子都关了，
他照样在做这个相关的业务，
而且那个业务基本上也是我的关系吧，
我之前那一些老关系也在做一点点，
但实际上已经完全入不时出了，
我自己20年没有说的日语已经很不流利了，
我前几天就跑去学他做那个日语主播，
但是学了三四天吧，
还不行，
就是你想问我啥问题，
你想让我帮你分析啥问题，
具体一点，
第一就是说他的悔改，
他也是四十几岁了，
他对小孩也确实是非，
趁好小女孩的话，
再怎么说有爸爸呢照顾我还是会好一点，
我觉得我就是太难受了。
然后第二个就是我自己的事业在一落千丈嘛，
把那个弄掉了以后就完全没有了，
现在就重新开始，
我到现在其实我还在想着，
如果说你那边，
如果说你实在周转不过来了，
你要把这些东西卖掉，
我说你虽然写在我名下，
但是你拿去卖，
但是我不会亲自给你贷款，
你拿去卖可以就这几点我都不知道我做的到底对还是不对，
我没有智会去处理这些东西，
我就感觉说来听一听龙飞姐这样的比较有智慧，
在你硬说一下，
我感觉啊，
所有东西要有一个集中气力，
你现在需要做的事情是转移你的注意力，
我要是你的话啊，
就是除了我睡觉的时间，
我遮眼的时间，
我肯定就得学习，
如果我想靠这个主播，
日语主播吃上这碗饭的话，
我睁眼就得背单词了，
我睁眼就得看看人家日语主播一天总共那些单词的话，
哪些是成功率比较高的，
我睁眼就得学一下他们的话。
术，
我闭上眼睛，
我都得听他们的直播，
听他们的话术，
我得先能挣到钱，
我得先能够有这个资本，
你别穷大方，
假大方，
什么说候房子他也能卖，
你能挣得回来吗？
你挣得回来就别那么假大方啊，
也不是说假大方，
因为孩子马上也是毕业做那个体制类有关的，
所以我也不希望他进去，
或者说不希望他出事，
确实是这样子呀，
那你以后的人生呢？
你老了怎么办呢？
你不能像一条丧家之犬一样，
就到处那个什么吧，
你先别管别人啊，
孩子的前途不外乎后说他是进私人单位还是进哪个单位的问题，
你呢，
你老了之后，
你不能挣钱了之后，
谁管你呢？
谁给你房子住啊，
谁你钱花呀，
对自己每天老是一想，
就是想到那上面去，
然后我跟你说好，
真的真的啊，
姐姐你比我年长几岁啊？
给自己付养老钱了吗？
给自己买养老保险了吗？
以后你靠什么活着？
就是职工保和医保的话，
那个就是协议里面签了他继续交难年性把他继续教，
他要是不教了，
那怎么办呢？
就自己教，
所以你现在别管男人，
别管孩子，
先管好你自己，
你怎么能够活着，
你怎么能够活着？
嗯，
赶紧的啊，
就日语赶紧捡起来，
人家那个日语主播，
那不光是日语的问题，
人家销售的策略，
人家销售的话术，
人家销售的节奏，
人家上货的节奏，
人家卡单的节奏，
都得学，
对也去听了三四天了，
闭上眼睛都得。
想如果是我的话，
我怎么就调动那个气氛是吧，
我怎么卡这个单，
我怎么能勾住人家买我这个货，
我怎么能够让别人对我的这个直播间产生兴趣，
我怎么能让人家对我这个人产生信任，
我怎么能让人家相信我买我的货你都得学啊。
嗯，
我看评论区有的时候做这个样子还想着指望男人，
这真的不是说指望男人，
因为一直也我就是算低价了，
我当二十几年的时候，
我就已经是比他，
我当时就1万多呢，
他比我还低，
就是因为自己那时候长得不好看，
现在刚才有朋友说看到我的那个不丑啊，
因为我做了一个鼻子，
我40来岁的时候才去做的，
自己确实又矮又丑，
但是我的认知就是觉得说我家庭不好，
然后呢，
自己不好看，
真的，
有时候家庭对孩子的影响真的是非常非常大的，
如果你的家庭让你感觉有低配得感，
那么你就做那个简短代际传承的人，
你让你的孩子有自信，
有高配得感，
同时也在治愈着咱们自己。
还有像那些说什么什么自己养活自己，
再生工厂是我们一起开的，
不是说他一个人开了养我的，
这么多年一直跟他开，
就是因为我就生孩子，
这几年我没有开，
我没有去公司管，
然后才出了这么大的乱子。
第一个问题，
你不知道怎么理顺现在的关系，
那我就告诉你，
现在唯一需要理顺的关系是你要出去找到你自己的自信，
你要找到你的价值，
你要找到你事业奋斗的。
的激情，
你要为自己的人生去盘算，
去为自己的养老去打算，
其他所有的事情的话都放在后面，
至于说以后要不要卖房子，
那以后再说啊，
我是不同意卖房子的啊。
至于说你老公要不要上黑名单，
他上了黑名单又能怎样？
孩子不能考公务员，
他也可以干别的好不好？
嗯嗯，
就这样啊莎莎，
嗯，
记得点赞关注哦。